Now that we have our UI set up, we need to start doing a little testing to make sure
that everything is going to work.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're going to pull in our little pickup object
and then we're going to set its score and its time so that when we run our project,
we have a score and a time set up and working.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the engine now.
All right, and now I have one already setting here, but if I don't have that, we're going
to hit control space and then what we want is we're going to come up to our content
and we're going to grab our pickup and we're just going to drop that in here.
Now inside the details panel, again, I should have a score and a time.
So maybe the score is 100 and the time is 10.
And I'm just going to bring this up a little bit.
So let's go ahead and hit play.
So there's our score and our time and there we go.
And it says timer.
So maybe I should make that say time.
So we'll just do this really quickly.
If I come over here to my, there we go, that one right there, get text zero.
We need to go over to the graph, time.
There we go.
And then let's just compile and save that.
And we're going to close this and then there we go.
That looks a little bit better.
So all right, that is working how we wanted it.
That's looking really, really good.
All right, so with our testing now completed and our next part, we're going to be taking
a look at creating UMG menu so that we can have a game over menu and some other menus
so that we can make a full game loop with this project.